[Music]
[Applause]
he's Ryan Leaf he's a college football
analyst NFL analyst and he's doing some
a lot of things with Westwood One Sirius
XM and the former number two overall
pick by the Chargers the 1998 draft did
you care about numerology like when you
picked your number when you played in
college or the pros how important was
that uh
it all started in high school and I
wanted my dad's number my dad wore
number 14. and so
coach lays out all the jerseys out on
the bleachers and it's first come first
serve and this this little kid who was
not going to play and was not gonna you
know whatever picks up 14 and I I looked
at him and I said hey you know that's my
dad's number can I and he flat out you
know you know said no and so the only
number left with the quarterback number
was 16. and so I took it and that's what
I wore the rest of my life did you want
to change it at any point once I had it
you know once I had it I you know
somebody started using this the kind of
the moniker sweet 16 and and so I I
rolled with it it still sounds like
you're bothered by this kid who took 14.
I even remember his name his name was
Bill Clark oh Bill Clark Paulie where is
Bill Clark right now Bill Clark we're
all over it yeah yeah he's not sitting
in a man cave being interviewed by me
that's for sure
um what's going on with Washington State
what's uh what's the future there it's
devastating uh
I mean this was an inevitability it
really was
we're on the precipice of the National
Collegiate Football League we just we
are it's gonna be two conferences
between 18 to 22 teams most likely that
can afford to be in there the meteorites
a deal it's going to be its own separate
entity probably no NCAA uh they're gonna
make a lot of money doing it
um and they're going to be teams that
are relegated and it just started sooner
rather than later I thought we may have
a few more years but the writing was on
the wall last year it just it was and
the fact that George cleofkoff and the
Board of Governors
did not move on that deal much faster
and allowed things to play out allowed
the Big 12 to really gain some momentum
after what went down last year it it
really led to this you didn't you
couldn't have been too surprised now
talking with President Schultz who was
the head of it from Washington State he
said he had everybody back to the table
um uh Friday morning and then right
before the meeting started Arizona was
like that one hold out and they got him
back to the table they were going to
sign the grant of rights deal to the
Pac-12 Conference in Oregon and
Washington came in and said we're going
to take the the Big Ten deal they were
just too fearful of the streaming aspect
of everything all right so what's the
time frame here realistic time frame
that you think we have the NFL model of
college football well uh how quickly
it's escalated over two years ago when
Oklahoma and Texas went to the SEC and
then USC and UCLA and then what what
completely evaporated uh I would suspect
within the next five years
and it feels like it's going to be Big
Ten commission you could have two
Commissioners the Big Ten commissioner
and the SEC commissioner and they could
oversee like the AFC and the NFC if you
wanted to you could but I ultimately
think there'll be one Czar okay yeah
whoever that may look like
um you know the Big Ten commissioner
right now is new of course after Warren
took the job with the Bears uh and and
what the SEC has accomplished but he's a
TV guy the Big Ten commission yes like
you that's what you need you got to have
TV has changed changed College athletics
changed college football I don't know if
it's going to be for the good because I
always think about this I get caught up
in it because I'm a member of the media
and I have to look at both sides if
you're a fan
is it good for you what is happening now
well I think you're going to get good
football I mean
I I just got the the big 12's game of
the week you know with ESPN on the
streaming service that they have ESPN
plus so I'm gonna get to go down and get
some really good Big 12 games some
Pac-12 teams are going to be involved
with it in the next few years you know a
lot more games so I think we're gonna
have some interesting good football
games so that doesn't bother me what
bothers me of course is the history the
Legacy all those things that exist from
when when I was a kid growing up you
know the Rose Bowl was going away anyway
it was going to this playoff and it was
not going to be used as the traditional
Big Ten Pac-12 uh game anymore and that
that was unfortunate I I just love the
venue and I love the game I don't
necessarily care who's playing in it but
yeah it's as a as a fan who's consuming
it it's got to be difficult and I've had
a lot of former players reach out to me
over the last couple days just you know
just in disbelief yeah I just I wonder
if you're a fan that you they don't care
that the volleyball team has to go to
you know Piscataway and play Rutgers or
the baseball team might be put out by
going someplace it's basically what do
you what do you have for me and if the
menu is still great you know maybe
there's less items on the menu but the
menu is strengthened because there are
going to be some good matchups you get
USC and UCLA in the Big Ten and you get
match-ups that you didn't have before
I'm just curious what happens with
Florida State Clemson and Notre Dame at
what point do they say
we're gonna we're gonna stay where we
are can we stay where we are is it time
to make that move well I think Florida
State pretty much told the world it's
time to make that move and
um I tell you what if they go out this
year and play like I think they are
um you know and and get back to the
championship level caliber team they are
with Mike Norvell and Jordan Travis the
quarterback that's that's going to speak
volumes I I wouldn't be surprised if we
see him in the SEC
yeah pretty darn quick here and then
that's the Domino that continues to fall
the ACC starts to crumble you look at
the two sides of things and then the
NCAA becomes you know essentially what
they are just a giant party planning
group every March and uh and we move
away from from all that
I've I've heard some uh former
quarterbacks talk about even Mike
Tannenbaum the former Jets GM saying he
would not start a rookie quarterback not
under any circumstances week one where
where we are with quarterbacks coming
out of college and you know it's already
a professional
you know system that they're running
um I know Mahomes didn't you know when
he came out and Carson Paul you know
we've had a lot of guys who didn't start
uh Steve McNair but where are we right
now with the state of quarterbacking CJ
Stroud should he be starting week one
Bryce young should he be starting week
one I mean it clearly looks like uh
they've uh they've adjusted to what
they're being asked to do but we all
felt that way I mean going into my first
game everybody was really confident with
what I had been doing in practice you
know and how we were moving along and in
fact we went out and won our first two
starts I didn't play you know
particularly well uh did you know what
you were doing
yeah I mean I knew what I was doing but
the things that I I was thinking too
much and and when you step out on a
football field when you're going through
the offense you don't want to be
thinking about anything other than what
you may see what them doing defensively
that's all you want to think about you
don't want to think about what did I
call on the snap count what protection
did I put here what happens if this
safety comes down do I move the back
over here to protect me on this side
that's just got to be second nature and
that's what happens when you've been in
a system that long you look at Players
like I mean Peyton Manning played his
entire career in the same offense Tom
Moore that offense it's never changed
even with Adam gase that came along that
was Peyton what he was doing uh and
making changes on his own so when you
have that ability that's a big part of
it so would you would you start CJ
Stroud for a bad team
I don't think Houston's that bad of a
team though so I think their offensive
line may be one of the best in the in
the in the league and if you have a good
offensive line a rookie quarterback can
he's going to hold the ball longer than
most guys do you just look at the
trajectory of where Tom Brady was in
year one two three and what he looked
like in year you know 15 where the ball
was out like that
so you have to that's a learning
progression you used to be able to hold
the ball back there Pat a little bit in
college you know take your time approach
you got to get rid of it and he's a
really good offensive line so I don't
have a problem with that all I the only
problem I always have is how involved
the teams are on when it goes bad when
failure does happen
because no one as we've talked about
this before can quantify that variable
you just don't know it hasn't happened
not many of these guys have faced
failure oh like you're playing at Ohio
State or Alabama okay may have lost one
game or two games in a season and then
he goes back to you go look at Bryce
young go back to modern day where you
just dominate in Southern Cal all the
time so and that's always what I want to
see from a Young quarterback when you
throw the interception when you get
sacked now what you what do you do not
when you throw a touchdown because the
true adversity of the position is and
everybody faces it what happens when you
know you get knocked on your rear end
yeah and and you just you don't know
what that's going to be like
um and um especially when you step up to
the mic after the game that's even the
bigger thing right to take ownership of
something that you may not feel was your
fault but since you're the quarterback
and you're the leader it is and also
when you're embarrassed and humiliated
because like you said these guys haven't
been embarrassed and humiliated playing
in a in front of everybody like you're
used to being so good at what you do
what happens when you step out there and
have a game like I did against Kansas
City my my third game and it's just
embarrassing and you're so humiliated
that you just you regress to this
defensive position and it just you know
back yourself into the corner start
fighting and it of course it completely
backfired on me and it's just always
dependent on these these players and
then how is the team going to back you
and support you in that process well
when do you start thinking about the
post game press conference while you're
in the game and you have a bad game you
don't and you don't even think about it
you don't even think about it in the
locker all of a sudden it's just like
this
thing that slaps you in the face and
you're standing in front of a microphone
and you have these people just going you
sucked what how did this happen you know
and then you look at the guy and you
think you know he's about you know 280
pounds and five foot four never played a
game of football and you're just like
going I am so much Superior then you
stop asking me stupid questions little
man and that doesn't work out well no
one does it
I know it didn't work out for somebody I
know yeah
um Jamar Chase said that he would have
no problem with Joe Burroughs sitting
out for maybe the first five games of
the regular season
what do you think well I mean that that
tells me a little bit more maybe about
the injury
you know yes
um
but he's so darn good
it just depends his AFC is so loaded and
we've talked about it ever since I was
here doing the show when we talked about
Lamar Jackson it was such a up in the
air thing on where he was going to be if
he was going to be back to Baltimore
there are probably 10 or 11 teams that I
would consider playoff caliber teams
there's going to be four that don't get
in and you're talking about quarterbacks
like Lamar Justin Herbert Russell Wilson
Aaron Rodgers possibly tuatanga Bella
all these guys so if you you know if if
you put yourself in a five-game hole
you know in a division like the AFC
North which is going to be brutally
competitive
you want to be the one seat
you don't want to go to Kansas City
again they've had to do it for the last
five years everybody has you want to be
the one seed you don't want to be the
five seed yeah and so uh that's a big
part of it you know you have to have 13
maybe possibly 14 wins I think in the
AFC to have the number one overall seed
this year well things I keep bringing
this up because everybody you know we we
kind of filter how we want to filter
it's like uh hey I'm gonna believe that
story it goes back to obj when the
Cowboys wanted him and and I I asked the
question on the show I said can he even
play is he healthy enough to play and it
you know that was what was true nobody
wanted to focus on that yeah he's not
going to play hey we need talking points
we can mention the Cowboys here so you
start to think about the AFC East
I think one team gets to the playoffs
out of the AFC East do you yes because
the AFC East is tough you play the NFC
east and the AFC West well how many wins
are you going to need to win that
division and is that going to be good
enough to make the wild you know have a
wild card team there
I I'm it's going to be tough sledding
here Buffalo we know is good Miami is
good that's it should be good should be
good yes see you know and New England
will be competitive you know they may be
average but still that's that's a pretty
tough division top to bottom nobody's
factoring that in they're like man the
Jets going to the Super Bowl well I mean
would you argue that's mostly Jets fans
no no no it's the national media is it
really
oh my God I have not been I think I'm
just so in my own head you can't watch
any of these shows without knowing it's
going to be about Dax well you got green
tea you got eyes in and they're freaking
Jets fans and so they you know I I start
talking about the reality like you said
uh of what's real here and jets fans
lose their Collective Minds
I mean I swear it's like I'm I've come
to them they could be a year early yes
which is is strange to sound with Rogers
at his his age but I think that's why
he's saying I'm gonna play here for a
few years I think he realizes if we do
catch lightning in a bottle it could be
amazing but give me a full year with
this lineup and you know then I think
that we might be really formidable do
you imagine us not being in the same
position next uh off season with him
deciding will he or won't he if they
don't go to the playoffs and if they
don't I can't I can't even think about
it I do I can't I think that's what it
is I can't wait what do you think
happens I think we just see the same
thing we've had happening if they don't
make the playoffs is Aaron Rodgers doing
the I don't know I gotta go into the
darkness and make it make a decision
I do I mean I think that's just I think
that's just kind of how he works and I
don't fault it necessarily have you been
and uh have you gone into the dark place
like when you've been in a dark place
it was called jail I spent three years
in that dark place
um you know it's I do a lot of
meditating now you know and I I try to
have done what Rogers did I couldn't do
it for that long
you know I spend I'll spend you know 30
minutes in a in a room right now where I
everything shut off I just closed my
eyes and I just I meditate but I I
couldn't do what he did I do that it's
called a nap
I mean but my mind starts dreaming about
and fantasizing about stupid stuff when
I'm when I'm sleeping it's not it's not
the productive type of stuff wait what
are you fantasizing about uh golf
simulators
[Laughter]
big time we're remodeling right now
we're putting one in nice yep uh how
much weight you lost
uh since 2020 like
like 80 85 pounds is 20 20.
so I've you know we've been working at
this for a while
um I'm gonna be an old dad a kid's gonna
be
uh I'm gonna be in my mid-60s when they
graduate from high school
um
and so I just you know the NFL does a
really good thing with the NFL PA and
they send us down to New Orleans to
Tulane University the medical school
there and we go through a huge brain and
body scan I just did it last week yeah
and um
and you know they take
probably it's probably six figures worth
of medical testing you get for free
it's amazing and it's you know I'm very
critical of the NFL and the nflpa all
the time but so I think it's really
important that I talk about the good
stuff they're doing for us former
players in that aspect of things because
they use this one ultrasound on your
heart where they can actually see inside
the ventricles and see how really the
plaque is otherwise you you don't know
that unless you have it cracked open
and they're able to see that because
that's the thing that that kills a lot
of us we don't know what's going on
there so I got a lot of good feedback
they had the numbers from 2016 when I
went last time and nothing concussion
wise they can't register they can't
really register but the tumor that I had
taken out which was trauma related was
almost you know the residual tumor was
almost zero which was which is amazing
uh you know it's food it's exercise it's
meditation it's prayer it's uh nature
and it's just I think
you know just kind of doing the same
things I've done over the last 10 years
well you look great uh my best to your
wife and uh I know you're heading up to
see your folks uh uh so your number one
analyst for the Big 12 game of the week
yeah on uh ESPN plus Westwood won your
podcasting as well the straight line
with uh Ryan Leaf you're a busy guy
there uh thanks for taking some time to
join us over here it's always good to
see you man always good to see you guys
I appreciate you that's why I heard
you're retiring though like in 2027 four
and a half years yeah yeah you know I'm
just down the road if you want to keep
doing the show and getting money I'll do
it for like 10 bucks a show if you want
okay all right easy commute I'm uh I'm
not surprised you threw your name in the
hopper yeah
yeah 2028 yeah
yeah but there's always Nick Wright who
he's younger is he younger yeah he looks
older he's a lot younger